So you can see on the front of this instrument
is a dome shaped device. That dome is a special
vessel which is made so we can control the
atmosphere inside and it is fabricated from
beryllium metal.
This is the beryllium which I don’t really
want to get out.
Why not?
Well, because it is a toxic chemical, a toxic
metal.
Beryllium is an interesting element because
most chemists don’t really know about it
very much at all.
So beryllium is a fantastic metal, it is really,
really interesting, it’s got really lots
of strange metallic properties, but one of
the most important to me is that it is transparent
to x-rays. So I can shine x-rays straight
through the beryllium and the beryllium does
not absorb it at all which most other metals
especially those with higher molecular weights
do.
Beryllium-laden dust has been shown to cause
berylliosis which is actually an industrial
lung disease which causes the formation of
swollen nodules in the lungs called granulomas
which is a bit gross, so I don’t really
want to open up the jar.
It’s near the beginning of the periodic
table, but we rarely come across it.
So at the moment we are at Matt’s lab and
we are doing some x-ray experiments on a really,
really quite sensitive compound. So X-rays
themselves are absorbed by everything, ok,
so when we shoot it through the air it is
absorbed by the air, so to measure the x-ray
absorption of our compound which is sensitive
to the air we need to be able to remove the
air and encase it so we use beryllium to make
a magic box around our sample, that the x-rays
can come into, interact with our sample, and
then exit without interacting with the material
around them. So you can see on the front of
this instrument, there is a dome shaped device,
that dome, is a special vessel which is made
so that we could control the atmosphere inside
and it is fabricated from beryllium metal.
I talk about in my lectures, I explain that
beryllium chloride the molecule that has three
atoms, two chlorine atoms and one beryllium
atom, has the three atoms arranged in the
row, so it is a straight molecule so called
linear molecule. I have never seen beryllium
chloride.
Chemists use it on x-ray defractometers because
actually it is so lightweight it is actually
got atomic number 4.
The beryllium allows the x-rays to come in
and out without interacting at all. It is
a fantastic device it is really useful for
really sensitive chemistry, it is a really
beautiful application. The cost of that beryllium
though, that is significant, that small beryllium
sample cost 15,000 Euros.
It only has four protons and a number of neutrons
so if x-rays fall on atoms of beryllium they
are not scattered very much so it’s like
the difference between shining light through
a glass window and if you made it out of a
heavy material it would be like, shining through
paper, it would be scattered you wouldn’t
get a good image.
I’m hoping to actually do some chemistry
with beryllium which is why I’ve bought
it. It is pretty toxic so we are going to
have to be very, very careful. You can’t
actually breathe in the dust at all, cause
even actually one exposure has shown with
some people one exposure is enough to cause
this sort of sensitive reaction.
But beryllium is very poisonous so if you
do use these beryllium windows, you have to
be careful not to lick your fingers. Well
good chemists shouldn’t lick their fingers
anyway.